so I fly you out to to do the cactus
thing yeah have you have you seen my new
book and and I have not yet I haven't I
haven't got to I I've had a couple
people tell me about I've had a few
comments on Instagram saying how much
they liked that that part of the book
yeah I mean I told you about it right
yeah you told me about it I just haven't
read it very good good because I got
pretty graphic
I got pretty graphic about how here you
know you were this crazy guy I just had
to meet you you know I I set it up as
the the context being that in general
I've not been really uh supportive or
you know not that I'm a hater but like
copycat stunt people like just doesn't
turn me on you know like I'm not there's
not really been like a copycat crew that
that I that I read that I got behind you
know yeah like it was it was you were
the exception to the rule yeah and that
was because what I saw you do was just
so gnarly it was so like there was just
something about it I was like I gotta
meet this guy so I fly you out
I send you into this [ __ ] Cactus and
then like almost as soon as you're
you're out of the cactus with with like
hundreds maybe thousands of cactus
needles all over your body yeah then
I'm just like oh my God this guy's gonna
get [ __ ] staph infection he's like
the the most unhealthy [ __ ] guy I I I
I I I I I extended your trip I brought
you to the [ __ ]
urgent care so like dude help this guy
and and they weren't even concerned
about the the needles all over you they
were concerned about how sunburned you
were right
to shoot yeah I like sun poisoning or
something they said they gave me like a
steroid for my sunburn and they were
just like yeah the needles will come out
with the antibiotics over time and
you'll just have to pull them out like
we can't do that like we're not gonna
pull them out dude I had like a team of
[ __ ] body waxers come over to the
house like waxing his skin hoping that
the wax would pull out the [ __ ]
needles like I was I was starting to
freak out like
and and so we're driving home from the
urgent care and I'm and all of a sudden
I'm just like yeah oh dude Zach like you
know
you you should start taking care of
yourself dude you know like I'm like you
uh
you know like and and then and then I
take it like another step further I'm
like dude the whole world loves uh a
[ __ ] transformation they love like
like if you were to like get healthy
like lose weight like the whole thing
then it would be like a whole other
level of opportunity for you you
wouldn't be like in you know the the
narrow pool of people who want to see
like dudes [ __ ] themselves up like that
would open you up to like Ellen
DeGeneres style shed like look at this
guy he changed himself and I was like
let me [ __ ] help you get healthy
let's bring you bring you out here so we
make this whole plan to fly Zack out and
actually move him to California to try
to help him get healthy I buy him a
[ __ ] car like a used car
yeah
we're driving off this [ __ ] used car
lot and Zach's just blowing through red
lights
and it turns out oh my God this kid's a
[ __ ] hardcore drug addict
why because he was running through red
lights or what how did that come back it
was like I wasn't even really like high
like when I came again
I'm fine okay I'm totally fine
also I've not had a lot of driving
experience at all like just in general
like no one ever taught me how to
[ __ ] drive like like growing up that
never [ __ ] happened so I am a shitty
driver no no question how'd you pass the
[ __ ] I don't know oh I did you passed
right I passed I passed in Indiana wait
wait so so so I mean dude you were
blowing through I was so nervous like
driving you too because I was like I
don't know it was super like early like
it was nice
like you just go through red lights and
there's a car like
the conversation come up to where like
he was a bad driver to like Bridging the
Gap of he's on drugs like it like it
should be like it became
first thing was oh my God like what's
going on with this kid I do not see that
as a [ __ ] red light you just blew
right through Steve's telling you you're
a bad driver
be clear
and clear like uh that what he's on
drugs he was on drugs that we had and I
remember thinking because because our
buddy Tommy's a big recovery guy like
we're all in recovery and and when it
came to our attention oh Zach's got a
problem with drugs
then all of a sudden we thought oh well
we're way better suited to help them
with that so
we like started trying to help you with
that yeah and that didn't go very well
at first no it didn't because you picked
up skateboarding
yeah
at the sober living I was really stoked
on that
um yeah I was skating and then like I
was like it was kind of cool just like I
was like like I was able to drop in I
was doing some other stuff and then one
of my friends was like oh you should do
this rolling grind but I can't like
Ollie so like there's no way I was gonna
get off safely he thought I would just
build it like somehow right off of it
and I just ride down and I fall like two
times before and he's like just try one
more time
and uh we try it I go again and I fall
off weird and my I land like all my
weight on my right leg like falling
backwards leg just snaps in half it was
it was the gnarliest break all right I
hate seeing footage like that I'm so
happy it was on video though at least
like it was like it was your leg Yeah it
was my leg break yeah tip FIB yeah
because both bones snapped yeah both
like and it wasn't even just like one
little break like it was like broke then
like under it broke so it was like there
was like a little middle piece it was
just there on each leg
I mean on each uh bone tip him I
remember feeling responsible for that
[ __ ] too I was just like Jesus well that
was definitely me and
then it was too the
two that we we put you in a sober living
like a halfway house and we're paying
for it and it was like okay Zach you
know like we're all about recovery and
like in hindsight it was so silly to to
expect that we could just like
push you into that you know like if I
like in hindsight if I think about it
from Zach's perspective it's like oh you
know like it's always been you know my
dream to like be like that you know a
jackass guy now I've got like the guy
from Jackass like of course you're gonna
tell us everything that we want to hear
you know of course it was like we were
dangling a carrot and uh you know and
and and of course you're gonna try to
pretend that everything but you just
didn't have it in you at that time no I
wasn't like really ready like to like
get better you know that time but like
looking back like if if that wouldn't
have happened like I wouldn't have like
I wouldn't have I probably wouldn't be
sober right now like because I wouldn't
even know I wouldn't even have known
about that stuff or like how to even
like fix that you know right the seed
was planted yeah it definitely helped me
like in the end you know right and then
in my book I talk about how like it you
know you weren't ready but then all of a
sudden like sometime later
uh you just got it on your own the seed
had been planted and then the seed
you know yeah the plant grew and uh and
and you were doing so great
with everything
and then at a certain point it became
well I mean then then Dad you were doing
great when you filmed the movie yeah it
was great during the movie
um but then after like the movie was
like done and everything I started like
I don't know something like things just
like I know he dripped it away yeah yeah
I remember telling you I was like dude
like you know we gotta we gotta kind of
stay involved in all of the stuff and
you're like just kind of gradually just
drifting away and not paying attention
to protecting your sobriety but I mean
it's got to be tough being on a number
one hit movie like how intoxicating was
that for you being on a red carpet like
whoa everybody knows who I am now I mean
did everybody know who you were
beforehand I mean somewhat but like
because I'm I'm just someone like I'm
sort of recognizable to begin with but I
mean the movie has helped so much you
know like it's it's opened up so much
for me I mean dude Zach was recognizable
as [ __ ] off the back of just the
firecracker vest and then the cactus
video let me do that Cactus video got
hundreds of millions of shoes yeah like
that that Cactus video made you oh super
recognized yeah it did yeah that was
like that helped so [ __ ] much yeah I
mean it's pretty crazy how uh how how
that happened and then um
I mean I don't know like of course the
jackass movie is a big deal too but um
as far as it's got to be tough staying
sober when you're in a number one movie
I mean dude
like
so it's like my guy always said to me
there's only one book there's no special
edition for special people yeah yeah
you're not special right the disease of
alcoholism and addiction does not
discriminate does not discriminate and
neither does recovery yeah
so uh I mean it's crazy it's so after
the movie happened or after the movie
came out what happened
um I sort of like just well I sort of
just was in a bad spot and like didn't
like I wasn't like I made like some
other like
show for like a little bit with Vinnie
that was the film yeah the fail army
thing I did that I did a few other
things you know I ended up doing Shark
Week
um there was just like a bunch of like
there's a bunch of things here and there
but like I I didn't really like
I was just in a bad spot like because I
was because I was using you know I
wasn't really like capitalizing I'm like
oh I should be like striking all the
Iron's hot right now you know what I
mean like and yeah everything just got
sort of gnarly for me yeah
um do you remember when we uh
pulled the intervention on you yeah I do
yeah I remember that you you talked a
pretty good game I was like we showed up
in your crib yeah
like like we showed up like practically
moments before the eviction notice
showed up
like and uh we were there waiting to
Ambush you when you got home from
something or other we're like hey he's
acted like you know we're worried about
you we want to
um offer for you to get you know to get
help and and make it completely free for
you and you're like no I'm fine dude I'm
totally fine okay like seriously I'm I'm
fine like it did it was kind of
convincing for him I believe I believed
yeah that was cocaine
yeah
I mean it's like when you're doing that
and you could come up on somebody that's
on drugs and they're like convincing but
like your spiders it's like a weird
thing because you're like
you sound convincing but like everything
in my gut is just being like this
[ __ ] guy is lying dude yeah I say you
talked a good game but
it was it was it was
well then I was like okay so so so you
mean to tell us that like if we leave
here you don't have if we go in your
house right now there's no drugs inside
and then when you totally looked away
from us and you're like yeah you could
totally do that's fine I was like all
right well they weren't in the house
they were in my pocket
right you know and and uh and and there
was just no getting through to you that
dude I'm totally fine I'm totally fine
it was like okay man you know and then
uh to your credit not too long after you
reached out and said hey man is that
offer still good and uh and man that
that's awesome dude I'm I'm super super
glad what made you call well I mean like
after you guys showed up like it was
like stuck in my head like maybe I
really [ __ ] do need to like go
[ __ ] I get this [ __ ] figured out you
know turned out he needed it pretty bad
yeah like it was just like how long can
I you know keep doing this for you know
and uh well how bad was it when we
showed up dude it was bad it was it was
pretty bad
I mean it was pretty bad
yeah it was it was really really bad and
um dude and it's so cool because
I uh you know had some people who I know
there was one guy who had offered a
scholarship to to me for somebody and I
was like man this is the scholarship
that dude came through with like
I think it was like 60 70 000 worth of
uh free treatment I mean dude that was
yeah and then and then and then uh
continued to with Aftercare all I had to
pay for was the detox
I paid for the Uber yeah thanks guys
medical detox is no joke either dude you
know like uh did you detox pretty good I
mean it was it was fine yeah I mean like
it was good that I was if I wouldn't
have had like the if I wouldn't have
been able to go to the detox it would
have [ __ ] sucked like so bad it was
opiates I mean dude yeah like no no
rehab is gonna take somebody in who's
not been yeah yeah because then when you
die in their care they get sued yeah
yeah what what if for those kind of
detoxes it just depends on the drug of
choice and then they give you some sort
of muscle relaxant for the week and yeah
what do they do it just like depends
like mine was it was for opiates benzos
and
cocaine and like and stuff like that
um yeah so they that was like three days
before you said you were fine
got it yeah
yeah I'm totally fine okay big pale
white yeah
seriously there's like literally nothing
wrong
I felt fine
so so that so you detox like a week and
then you got right into the yeah then I
did that stuff and you know did you you
did you detox I was in
um yeah I was I was a detox I don't know
that I was like was it like a what do
they call that medically induced detox
or nothing like that nothing like that I
mean the the rehab I went had a detox in
it so it wasn't like I went to a detox
and then a rehab it was just all built
into one place because that's like if
you're like a hardcore Drinker you want
to detox somebody so they don't like
convulse and like have a seizure yeah
and then for for opiates you don't want
like the withdrawal process and you
don't want it yeah I mean it's medical
deal you know like a d the the detox we
sent Zach to is basically like a
hospital there's a there's doctors there
like me yeah like
um it's what's life like now after
um I mean things are looking so much
[ __ ] better for me honestly yeah
um yeah and I just I don't know I feel
like I get I know I have like the want
and like the will like I don't know I
want to do [ __ ] like I want to like get
out there and like make sure to happen
you know
like I just feel like so much better
like overall I mean you've always had
that yeah but I mean like if there has
been motivated you've always been
wanting to uh be successful
and and you've always been teachable
like um so I I think I I see good things
for you if you just like I've always
said if you make the recovery your
number one priority your only priority
everything else would just come together
yeah everything else doesn't even need
to just just worry about about being in
recovery yeah do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude